del músico estadounidense Keith Jarrett.
Asistirían 1400 personas.
Y en apenas unas horas,
Jarrett saldría al mismo escenario,
se sentaría al piano
y, sin ensayo ni partitura,
comenzaría a tocar.
Pero ahora mismo,
Vera estaba presentando a Keith el piano en cuestión,
y algo no iba bien.
Jarrett miró el instrumento con un poco de cautela,
tocó algunas notas,
caminó alrededor,
tocó algunas notas más,
murmuró algo a su productor.
Luego el productor se acercó a Vera y le dijo:
"Si no consigues un piano nuevo, Keith no podrá tocar".
Había habido un error.
El teatro de la ópera le había dado el instrumento equivocado.
Tenía un registro alto, duro, de hojalata,
porque todo el fieltro se había desgastado.
Las notas negras sobresalían,
las notas blancas estaban desafinadas,
los pedales no funcionaban
y el piano en sí era demasiado pequeño.
No crearía el volumen
para llenar un gran espacio como el de la Ópera de Colonia.
Así que Keith Jarrett se fue.
Fue a sentarse fuera en su auto,
dejando que Vera Brandes
intentara encontrar por teléfono un piano sustituto.
Ella tenía un afinador de pianos, pero
no podía conseguir un piano nuevo.
Por eso salió a la calle
y se quedó bajo la lluvia
hablando con Keith Jarrett,
rogándole que no cancelara el concierto.
Él miró fuera de su auto
a esa adolescente alemana desaliñada, empapada por la lluvia,
se compadeció de ella
y le dijo:
"Nunca lo olvides... solo por ti".
Y así un par de horas más tarde,
Jarrett, efectivamente, salió al escenario del teatro de la ópera,
se sentó ante ese piano intocable
y comenzó.
(Música)
En unos momentos se hizo evidente que algo mágico sucedía.
Jarrett estaba evitando esos registros superiores,
se aferraba a los tonos medios del teclado,
que le daban a la pieza un ambiente relajante.
Pero también, dado que el piano estaba tan suave,
tuvo que configurar estos sonidos, esos riffs repetitivos en el bajo.
Y se puso de pie serpenteando, golpeando las teclas,
tratando desesperadamente de crear volumen para llegar a la gente de atrás.
Fue una actuación electrizante.
En cierto modo fue pacífica,
y a la vez llena de energía,
dinámica.
Al público le encantó.
Y le sigue encantando al público
porque la grabación del concierto de Colonia
es el álbum de piano más vendido en la historia
y el disco solista de jazz más vendido en la historia.
A Keith Jarrett le metieron en un lío.
Él desafió el lío y remontó vuelo.
Pero pensemos por un momento en el instinto inicial de Jarrett.
No quería tocar.
Claro,
creo que ninguno en una situación remotamente similar,
sentiría lo mismo, tendría el mismo instinto.
No queremos que nos pidan hacer un buen trabajo con malas herramientas.
No queremos tener que sortear obstáculos innecesarios.
Pero el instinto de Jarrett estaba equivocado,
y por suerte cambió de opinión.
Y creo que nuestro instinto también está equivocado.
Creo que tenemos que apreciar más
las ventajas inesperadas de tener que enfrentar un poco de lío.
Les daré algunos ejemplos
de la psicología cognitiva,
de la ciencia de la complejidad,
de la psicología social,
y por supuesto, del rock 'n' roll.
Primero, la psicología cognitiva.
Sabemos desde hace un tiempo
que ciertos tipos de dificultad,
cierto tipo de obstáculos,
en realidad pueden mejorar nuestro rendimiento.
Por ejemplo,
el psicólogo Daniel Oppenheimer,
hace unos años,
trabajó con profesores de secundaria.
Les pidió que cambiasen el formato de los apuntes
que daban en algunas de sus clases.
Los apuntes normales tenían formato sencillo
con fuente Helvetica o Times New Roman.
Pero a la mitad de estas clases se les dio apuntes formateados
con tipografía intensa como Haettenschweiler,
o con un giro informal como Comic Sans en cursiva.
Son fuentes muy feas,
y difíciles de leer.
Al final del semestre
llegaron los exámenes,
y a los estudiantes que tuvieron fuentes más difíciles de leer,
les fue mejor en los exámenes
en muchas asignaturas.
Esto se debe
a que la fuente difícil hizo que fueran más lentamente,
los obligó a trabajar un poco más arduamente,
y a pensar un poco más en lo que estaban leyendo,
para interpretarlo...
por eso aprendieron más.
Otro ejemplo.
La psicóloga Shelley Carson ha probado en estudiantes de Harvard
la calidad de sus filtros de atención.
¿Qué quiero decir con esto?
Quiero decir, imaginen que están en un restaurante,
están conversando,
hay todo tipo de conversaciones en el restaurante,
Uds. quieren filtrarlas,
quieren centrarse en lo importante para Uds.
¿Pueden hacerlo?
Si pueden, tienen filtros de atención buenos y fuertes.
A algunas personas realmente les cuesta hacerlo.
Algunos de los estudiantes de Carson lucharon con eso.
Tenían filtros débiles, tenían filtros porosos,
incorporaban mucha información externa.
O sea, eran interrumpidos constantemente
por imágenes y sonidos del mundo circundante.
Si había una TV encendida mientras estaban haciendo sus ensayos,
no podían apartarse de la pantalla.
Podría pensarse que eso era una desventaja...
pero no.
Cuando Carson analizó los logros de estos estudiantes,
los que tenían filtros más débiles
tenían más probabilidad
de haber tenido hitos creativos reales en sus vidas,
de haber publicado su primera novela,
de haber lanzado su primer álbum.
Estas distracciones eran en realidad ayudas en su proceso creativo.
Pudieron pensar con creatividad porque había muchos vacíos.
Hablemos de la ciencia de la complejidad.
Cómo resolver los problemas complejos.
El mundo está lleno de problemas complicados.
¿Cómo resolver un problema realmente complicado?
Por ejemplo, un motor a reacción.
Hay muchísimas variables,
la temperatura de funcionamiento, los materiales,
las diferentes dimensiones, la forma.
No se puede resolver ese tipo de problemas de una vez,
es muy difícil.
¿Qué hacer entonces?
Bueno, algo que se puede hacer es tratar de resolverlo paso a paso.
Uno tiene un prototipo,
le hace ajustes, lo prueba, lo mejora.
Le hace ajustes, lo prueba, lo mejora.
Esta idea de ganancias marginales con el tiempo da un buen motor a reacción.
Y ha sido ampliamente implementado en el mundo.
Van a oír de eso, por ejemplo, en el ciclismo de alto rendimiento;
los diseñadores web hablan de optimizar sus páginas web,
buscan logros paso a paso.
Es una buena manera de resolver un problema complicado.
¿Pero saben qué haría que sea una mejor manera?
Un poco de lío.
Se añade aleatoriedad,
desde el principio en el proceso,
se hacen movimientos locos,
se intentan cosas tontas que no deberían funcionar,
y eso tenderá a hacer que funcione mejor la resolución del problema.
Y la razón de esto es que
el problema con el proceso paso a paso,
las ganancias marginales,
es que pueden llevarnos gradualmente a un callejón sin salida.
Y si uno empieza con aleatoriedad, eso se vuelve menos probable,
y la resolución del problema se vuelve más robusta.
Hablemos de psicología social.
La psicóloga Katherine Phillips, con algunos colegas,
recientemente le dio problemas de misterio y asesinato a estudiantes.
Los estudiantes formaron grupos de cuatro personas
y recibieron expedientes con información sobre un crimen,
coartadas y pruebas, declaraciones de testigos y tres sospechosos.
Se le pidió a cada grupo que encontrase al culpable
de cometer el crimen.
Y había dos tratamientos en este experimento.
En algunos casos los cuatro eran amigos,
se conocían bien entre ellos.
En otros casos,
eran tres amigos y un extraño.
Y pueden ver a dónde apunto con esto.
Obviamente diré que
los grupos que tenían al extraño resolvieron el problema con más eficacia,
lo cual es verdad, así fue.
Resolvieron el problema de manera mucho más eficaz.
Los grupos de cuatro amigos,
tuvieron solo una probabilidad del 50 % de responder bien.
Eso no es muy bueno
en opciones múltiples para tres respuestas, 50-50 no lo es.
(Risas)
Los tres amigos y el extraño,
aunque el extraño no tuviese información adicional,
aunque se diera el caso
de cambiar de conversación para acomodarse al inconveniente
de los tres amigos y el extraño,
tenían 75 % de probabilidad de encontrar la respuesta correcta.
Es un gran salto en el rendimiento.
Pero pienso que es muy interesante
no solo que a los tres amigos y al extraño les fuera mejor,
sino cómo se sintieron al respecto.
Cuando Katherine Phillips entrevistó a los grupos de cuatro amigos,
ellos pasaron un buen momento,
pensaron también que hicieron un buen trabajo.
Fueron complacientes.
Cuando habló con los tres amigos y el extraño,
no la habían pasado bien,
era más bien difícil, más bien raro...
y tenían muchas dudas.
Pensaban que no habían hecho un buen trabajo, pero sí lo hicieron.
Y pienso que eso es un muy buen ejemplo
del desafío que estamos viendo aquí.
Porque, sí...
la fuente fea,
el extraño torpe,
el movimiento aleatorio...
estas interrupciones ayudan a resolver problemas,
nos ayudan a ser más creativos.
Pero no sentimos que nos estén ayudando.
Sentimos que se interponen en el camino...
por eso nos resistimos.
Y por eso el último ejemplo es muy importante.
Quiero hablar de alguien
del mundo del rock 'n' roll.
Lo van a conocer, es un TEDero.
Se llama Brian Eno.
Es un compositor de música ambiente, brillante.
Es también catalizador
de algunos grandes álbumes del rock 'n' roll de los últimos 40 años.
Trabajó con David Bowie en "Heroes",
trabajó con U2 en "Achtung Baby" y en "The Joshua Tree",
trabajó con DEVO,
trabajó con Coldplay, trabajó con todos.
Y ¿qué hace para hacer a estas grandes bandas de rock aún mejores?
Bueno, hace lío.
Interrumpe en sus procesos creativos.
Hace el papel del extraño torpe.
Hace el papel del que les dice
que tienen que tocar con el piano intocable.
Y una de las maneras de crear esta interrupción
es mediante este notable mazo de cartas.
Tengo mi copia autografiada aquí, gracias Brian.
Se llaman Estrategias Oblicuas,
las desarrolló junto con un amigo.
Cuando están en el estudio,
Brian Eno toma una de las cartas.
Saca una al azar,
y hace que la banda siga las instrucciones de la carta.
Esta dice...
"Cambia de instrumento".
Sí, todos intercambian instrumentos, el baterista al piano.
Brillante, brillante idea.
"Analiza los detalles más embarazosos. Amplifícalos".
"Haz una acción de manera intempestiva, destructiva, impredecible. Incorpórala".
Estas tarjetas distraen.
Pero han demostrado su valor álbum tras álbum.
Los músicos las odian.
(Risas)
Phil Collins tocaba los tambores en uno de los primeros álbumes de Brian Eno.
Estaba tan frustrado que empezó a lanzar latas de cerveza por el estudio.
Carlos Alomar, gran guitarrista de rock,
estaba trabajando con Eno en el álbum "Lodger" de David Bowie,
y en un momento se giró a Brian y le dijo:
"Brian, este experimento es estúpido".
El tema es que resultó ser un álbum bastante bueno,
pero también,
Carlos Alomar, 35 años después, ahora usa las Estrategias Oblicuas.
Y pide a sus estudiantes que usen las Estrategias Oblicuas
porque se ha dado cuenta de algo:
Que no te guste, no significa que no te sea de ayuda.
Las estrategias en realidad no eran un mazo de cartas al principio,
eran simplemente una lista
que estaba en la pared del estudio.
Una lista de cosas para probar cuando se acababan las ideas.
La lista no funcionó.
¿Saben por qué?
Les faltaba desorden.
El ojo recorría la lista
y podía detenerse en la opción menos perjudicial,
en la menos problemática,
y se desvirtuaba la idea por completo.
Brian Eno se dio cuenta de que
sí, tenemos que hacer experimentos tontos,
tenemos que lidiar con los extraños torpes,
tenemos que tratar de leer las fuentes feas.
Esas cosas nos ayudan.
Nos ayudan a resolver problemas,
nos ayudan a ser creativos.
Pero también...
necesitamos un poco de persuasión para aceptar esto.
Por la razón que sea...
sea por la fuerza de voluntad,
sea sacando una carta,
o por culpa de una adolescente alemana,
todos, de vez en cuando,
necesitamos sentarnos y tratar de tocar el piano intocable.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)